what is up everybody it's anna mack here
for anime opera and today i will be
breaking down the latest installment of
the boku no hero story and this is
another one that just hits right in the
fields deku's friends and teachers try
to defend him from anti-deku protesters
the shocking truth about the ua security
system is revealed and deku may be about
to surpass all might but that could be
more of a curse than a blessing so let's
get into it if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no hero
content on the channel you know what to
do just leave a quick like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps with
the youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new here or you watch our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we start off with a
flashback to before class 1a set out to
find deku as they are discussing the
whole deku situation with nezu and
endeavor ida is convinced that if they
can find deku and bring him back to the
ua the civilians who are being sheltered
there will actually feel safer because
deku is there um about that ida but
let's move on at this point nezu and
endeavor are still not quite sure what
is the best course of action but nezu
does point out that the ua has the
greatest defensive technology in all of
japan in fact its entire security system
was recently updated and we're not
talking like some extra cameras and
padlocks no this is something completely
different the ua is now basically a
moving armored fortress yeah for real
apparently the different parts of the ua
campus have been divided into sections
and these sections can now be moved
underground using a massive system of
motorized elevators this is so insane
that even the characters in the story
are shocked by it and kaminari is like
dude that sounds like something out of a
mecca anime and i have to say that i
agree with coming out of here even in
the more futuristic world of mha a
security system of this caliber would
cost billions and billions of dollars
and that's not even the whole story nezu
explains that the underground sanctuary
beneath the ua has been reinforced with
3 000 steel plates and if there is any
interference detected within any of
these plates the underground evacuation
system will activate immediately on top
of that the ua underground fortress is
connected to shikitsu high which also
has a crazy security system that is
almost comparable to the ua and since
shikatsu is supposed to be on the other
side of the country you can imagine how
long these underground tunnels that
connect the two schools must be tokuyami
notices that these security systems and
in particular those steel plates seem to
be designed to resist shigaraki's decay
because these plates are not all
touching each other and they are
separated from each other underground
that will presumably stop shigaraki's
decay from spreading from one plate to
another when tokuyami points out that
this security system had to have been
put in place before shigaraki awakened
the full power of his quirk nezu
explains that he had anticipated that
something like that might happen and so
he prepared for it ahead of time oh and
by the way just as a little side note
nezu was apparently the one who paid to
have this entire completely insane
security system installed like what
is nezu supposed to be lex luthor or
something endeavour then jumps in and
explains that nezu has made tremendous
contributions to the education and
development of quirks and he is
recognized for it worldwide which i
guess implies that nezu is some filthy
rich tech billionaire presumably nezu
came up with a bunch of quirk related
inventions that made him a ton of money
cause i don't really see any other way
for him to be able to pay for such an
insane security system out of pocket i
guess nezu is basically the elon musk of
mha he's like some brilliant and
eccentric billionaire inventor who i
guess works as a principal for fun man i
can totally see someone making a nezu
coin now and trying to pump it as the
next big crypto anyway nezu eventually
agrees that the students should go out
and find deku and bring him back to ua
and that's exactly what they ended up
doing so back in the present that crowd
of people that we saw in the previous
chapter are still furious the deck was
being allowed to enter the ua grounds
these people are already frustrated by
how epically the heroes failed to
protect law and order and now after
being promised that they would be
completely safe within the ua they're
being told that deku the primary target
for the villains will be staying there
with them now from our perspective this
is of course incredibly unfair to deku
deku has been out there risking his life
and practically working himself to death
in order to protect these people from
the villains and yet instead of being
grateful they want him as far away from
them as possible however in order to
understand why the general public feels
this way we need to back up a second and
think about where they're coming from we
have to remember that the general public
doesn't really know anything about deku
and one for all the stuff about one for
all in particular has been hidden away
even from some of the people closest to
deku so we can be sure that random
people on the street don't know very
much about what is actually going on on
top of that the younger generations of
the japanese population probably don't
even know who all for one is they don't
know if this guy is supposed to be a
human or a nomu or why he's been alive
for so long and so on we as readers have
all of that information about deku about
one for all and about all for one but we
have to remember that the general people
of japan do not have this information so
it makes sense that they would be so
confused and scared and paranoid we know
that deku is all might successor and the
best hope that the heroes have of
defeating the villains but again the
general public doesn't know that for
them deku is just this random guy who
seems to have multiple quirks which is
sus in and of itself because having
multiple quirks is kind of like all for
one's thing and so the people don't
trust this deku guy to protect them as
the protesters continue to freak out
about deku's arrival we get to see a
whole bunch of familiar faces in the
crowd including deku's mom monomaine
arie ragdoll and kota and more some of
the heroes and teachers are trying to
calm the crowd down and reassure them
but the crowd continues to get more and
more restless best genius attempts to
explain that keeping deku here and
making sure that he is at his strongest
is actually the best strategy for
defeating the villains but the crowd is
frustrated about the complete collapse
of the hero society and the chaos that
ensued and so they continued to lash out
at the heroes and blame the heroes for
everything that went wrong the anxiety
of the crowd soon reaches a boiling
point and it looks like a full-blown
riot is about to break out but that is
when ochako jumps into action quite
literally as zochiko's parents look on
from the crowd she uses her quirk to
jump on top of the ua building and she
then uses a megaphone to speak directly
to the large crowd ochako reveals that
deku left the ua precisely because he
didn't want to put anyone in danger it
was the students herself included who
decided to bring deku back and as we
know deku was so stubborn about not
going back to ua that they basically had
to make him come by force ochako
explains that deku has a very special
power a power that is uniquely suited
for defeating all for one that is the
reason why all for one is targeting deku
but it's also the best hope that the
people of japan have in terms of
actually defeating all for one and the
villains ochako tells the crowd to take
a look at deku and the terrible state
that he is in because he has been
working so hard to protect everyone he
kept moving and fighting the villains
tirelessly for days on end even though
he was being targeted by the worst of
the villains and he could have been
killed at any moment several people in
the crowd seem to be finally getting the
message and we see the furry girl that
we met back in chapter 310 as she
recognizes deku as the boy who saved her
as you will recall she was being
attacked by a bunch of hooligans just
because of the way she looked but deku
came and rescued her ochako proclaims
that even though deku has a special
power he is not a special person he is
just a regular guy he's a normal person
like everyone else but he still fights
hard and gives it his all in the name of
protecting others this is what makes
deku a true hero he is not superhuman he
deals with all the same problems and
challenges as everyone else and yet he
still keeps pushing forward for the sake
of others ochako believes that although
taking the first step is always hard
taking this step of actually accepting
deku will lead to the birth of a true
hero a hero who will surpass even all
might deku has the potential to become
the greatest hero the world has ever
known a hero greater than all might but
the people need to take a leap of faith
and believe in him and that is how this
chapter ends by hitting us right in the
fields yet again
and you know what as i am taking in this
conflict between deku's friends and
teachers who are trying to protect him
and the general public who don't want
him anywhere near them i can't help but
think that all might is partially
responsible for this current state of
the hero society and i know what you're
probably thinking all might was like the
strongest and most effective hero ever
how could any of this madness be his
fault but even though all might was an
absolute legend and even though he had
the best of intentions he did make one
crucial mistake he tried to do
everything on his own he tried to save
everyone and be the perfect hero and
because he was so successful as the
symbol of peace the people of japan came
to rely on him and the heroes in general
for pretty much everything if we want
evidence of the fact that people
depended way too much on the heroes and
expected the heroes to take care of
pretty much everything for them all we
need to do is think back to shigaraki's
backstory one of the main reasons why
shigaki rejected the hero society and
became a villain was the fact that back
when he desperately needed help as a
child no one would help him because they
just expected some hero to do it for
them eventually it was all for one a
villain who finally ended up helping
shigaraki and that is as ironic as it is
tragic we know that deku has always
loved and looked up to all might but he
needs to avoid making the same mistake
as almai did as i said all might had the
best of intentions but he inadvertently
set up an extremely unrealistic standard
for heroes and once all might could no
longer maintain that standard himself
everything fell apart daku definitely
has the potential to surpass all might
and since he is the protagonist we know
he almost certainly will surpass him but
as much as deku loves all might and as
much as he tries to model his career on
almight's hero career deku needs to
learn from all might's biggest mistake
it is not realistic for a hero to always
be smiling it is not realistic for a
hero to always save everyone on his own
and it is not realistic for one hero to
become the symbol of peace the living
representation of everything that is
good and pure for an entire society deku
is not some saint or savior or messiah
like ochako said deku has an incredible
quirk but at the end of the day he's
just a normal guy like everyone else and
the same goes for all might deku still
faces challenges like the rest of us he
still feels fear anxiety self-doubt
sadness and many other normal human
emotions trying to be the symbol of
peace for an entire society is too much
pressure for one man
and trying to do everything on your own
so that no one else is ever put in
danger is just physically impossible all
might tried to do exactly that on many
occasions he tried to shoulder the
entire burden on himself in order to
protect everyone else and although he
was incredibly successful for a while he
eventually received a serious injury
which ultimately led to his retirement
deku has learned a lot of great lessons
from his mentor and true father all
might but he needs to part ways with all
might when it comes to depending on
others for example deku's classmates
have demonstrated the readiness
willingness and ability to support deku
and help him out in difficult situations
they even saved deku from certain doom
after he pushed himself too far in his
attempt to be like almight and save
everyone on his own it is now time for
deku to learn to trust others and to
work together with other people not only
is that the right thing to do for
himself and for his own mental health
but it is also the right thing to do for
the hero society as a whole the people
of japan should not expect one man to
take the burden of the entire country
upon his shoulders they should not
expect some larger than life figure like
all might to save everyone and solve
every problem everyone needs to take
responsibility for making society better
and everyone needs to work together
towards that common goal heroes are
great and they're an extremely useful
aspect of that society but heroes can't
do everything and save everyone on their
own everyone has to do their part
whether they're heroes or just regular
citizens
i think that this is the big lesson that
the previous arc has tried to teach us
and i really hope that deku will take
that lesson to heart but let me know
what you guys think did all might
inadvertently sabotage deku and the hero
society as a whole by setting an
unrealistic and unattainable standard
for what a true hero should be
is deku going to learn from all might's
mistakes and begin relying on others
once in a while also now that we've
gotten such a detailed breakdown of the
ua security system is that foreshadowing
that the ua is going to turn into a
major battlefield at some point in the
future finally what is going on with
nezu is he some eccentric tech
billionaire and if he is why is he
working as the principal at ua i mean
why isn't he creating his own space
rockets like every other self-respecting
billionaire don't forget to share your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more boku no hero content right here
on the channel don't forget to leave a
like it only takes a second but it helps
a lot and if you're new here or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a quick thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he is
an absolute mad lad and disciple of lord
twego himself and i can't forget all of
our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
ingrata pate heffa algital hinokamian
water the toasted chi the spike dylan
issador spidey life tinel tungsten
tarcus big buddhist and monkey d quilly
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red-haired raven angel
crews ratheora very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks joanne garcia ted no ted
fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul ray
slice and dice if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patreon exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you